OK.
It's I guess it's as good a time as ever to
have this conversation, if not now, when.
Right.
And I know that there's people in my audience
who aren't going to like this.
And they're going to be mad at me and they're
going to disagree and they're going to dislike
the video and they're going to unsubscribe.
And a few, even the really special ones will
even say anti-Semitic things.
And we'll say, I'm a bad person and I'm a
shill, but I can't care about that anymore.
You know, I do stories as I see them.
You guys have seen this throughout the election
cycle.
Sometimes we lose 500 subscribers.
Sometimes we gain 500.
Who knows?
I don't care.
It's too serious.
And so we have to do it.
Vote blue no matter who.
Here we go now is not the same as vote Biden
over Trump.
All right, let's think this through.
We've got to understand this before things
swirl out of control.
There is a very reasonable debate to be had
about Joe Biden's policies when Joe Biden
says he supports the Green New Deal as a framework.
What does that mean versus saying he would
push for specifically the Green New Deal?
That's a debate.
That's a great debate to have.
But we can't equate vote blue no matter who
to saying.
I believe Biden would be better than Trump
specifically.
And there are many supporters who have been
correctly tweeting me.
I want to be very clear.
You guys are right.
When you say, David, vote blue, no matter
who relinquishes agency.
It says to the DNC, you don't have to earn
my vote because I'm voting blue no matter
who I'm going to vote for.
Whoever has a D next to their name, no matter
who they are or what their platform is.
That's absolutely correct.
That being said, that's not what I or many
others are advocating for.
I have never said vote blue no matter who.
And in fact, I've said quite the opposite.
All along I've said I evaluate candidates
and decide who's better.
It's not a party analysis.
And then I say, do I prefer this person to
Donald Trump or do I prefer Donald Trump vote
blue?
No matter who would be saying, I'm not evaluating
candidates.
I'm merely going to vote based on whether
someone is a Democrat.
That's not what I do.
Biden is better than Trump on a number of
different issues.
I've talked about a lot of them.
And of course, all of these are up for debate
on judges, including the Supreme Court.
I don't want Trump choosing Ruth Bader Ginsburg's
replacement.
I want Biden choosing Ruth Bader Ginsburg
replacement, if you would prefer it be Bernie.
Great.
That's not the choice.
The choice is Biden or Trump.
And I prefer Biden on climate.
Biden supports the Green New Deal as a framework.
Trump doesn't.
Trump thinks climate change is a hoax created
by the Chinese.
Biden's better on that.
Taxes.
Is Biden's tax plan as progressive as Bernie's?
No.
Is Biden's tax plan better than Trump's?
Yes.
On health care is Biden's tax plan.
The progressive gold standard?
No, not even close.
Is it way better than what Trump tried to
do a couple of years ago?
Of course it is on diplomacy.
Is Biden an embarrassment?
Around the world the way Trump is?
No.
You might not like the things Biden will do
with his diplomatic skills and with his experience.
But there's no question that it's better than
Trump.
So back when it was Bernie and Warren and
Amy and Pete and Biden, at that point when
there were five possible candidates who could
who could win.
It still wasn't vote blue, no matter who it
was.
When I look at these five, any of these five
individuals would be better than Donald Trump
and I would vote for any of them.
When it was down to Bernie and Biden as the
last two contenders, I still wasn't vote blue
no matter who.
I'm not even a Democrat.
Remember, it was either of these two specific
people Bernie or Biden would be better than
Trump.
And likewise, at this point, this is not vote
blue no matter who.
For me, it's given the choices we now have
either.
Donald Trump will be reelected in November
or Joe Biden will be elected.
And Donald Trump will be removed.
That is the choice I am making and why I will
be voting for Joe Biden.
And, you know, if the language continues to
be arguing about the principle of vote blue
no matter who.
We're missing the forest for the trees.
The debate over vote blue, no matter who is
a principal, is a valid debate.
And that's not the debate that we are having
right now in terms of whether to choose Biden
specifically over Donald Trump.
Now, you might prefer Trump to Biden by all
means than vote for Trump or stay home or
write someone in or whatever.
But let's not live in this fantasy world where
we're pretending that this is about the principle
of if the DNC doesn't earn my vote, then they
don't deserve it.
Well, has Trump earned what is de facto your
support if you choose to stay home or write
someone in?
Because the idea that it's neutral to vote
for neither of them is one of the false notions
that we've been trying to dispel for years
on the program.
So if you're okay with your actions helping
Trump get get reelected, then do whatever
you want.
I'm not going to fight with people.
I'm not going to attack people.
I understand that there are many people who,
if it's not going to be Bernie, would rather
it be Trump than Biden either, because they
think that it's.
A message to the DNC or they have a burn it
all down to build it back up mentality or
they want to punish you.
That's fine.
But let's just be honest that that's what
you're doing.
If that is what you were going to do, I won't
argue with you on principle as long as you're
honest and take responsibility for what it
is that you're doing.
I just don't want people to mistake.
Vote blue no matter who wins, saying the options
are Biden and Trump and I prefer Biden to
Trump.
Switch their party affiliations.
Tell me Biden's the Republican and trumps
the Democrat.
Biden's still better.
That's the reality.
Let's not mistake a debate over Trump versus
Biden with the debate over the idea of vote
blue no matter who.
Cause that's not going to get us
very far.